Jason Kelce may have just one uped his
brother we all know Travis Kelce is
dating the biggest pop star in the world
but now Jason Kelce is one of the
sexiest men in the world he's officially
featured in people Magazine's 2023
sexiest man alive Edition Jason was
utterly shocked when he found out the
news saying that he isn't even the
sexiest man in his family let alone
alive he followed up by saying his head
definitely did not need to get any
bigger walking around the house so
instead of everyone losing their marbles
over his brother Travis and his love
life they need to maybe start directing
their attention to the other Kelsey
brother